[Music]
more drama between Selena Gomez and her
mom Mandy TV after publicly voicing her
disapproval of Selena rekindling a
romance with Justin Bieber TV is now
speaking out about her daughter's
decision to star in Woody Allen's
upcoming film a rainy day in New York
she threw jobs on Instagram after one
user called for Selena to write an
apology about the Woody Allen films TV
replied to the comment writing sorry no
one can make Selena do anything she
doesn't want to I had a long talk with
her about not working with him and it
didn't click no matter how hard you try
to advise it falls on deaf ears of
course working with Allen has been a
controversial choice for actors for
years reignited in 2014 when his
daughter Dylan Farrow went public with
accusations that he molested her as a
child Allen has denied the accusations
and investigations into the matter have
resulted in no charges against the
filmmaker Selena's co-star Timothy
sha'lame is also speaking out about the
movie it was very much a humbling
experience on Monday he announced on
Instagram that he plans to donate his
entire salary from the film to three
charities including time's up it's an
important conversation moving forward
and it feels great to be part of this
new generation in a new wave that is
more conscious about these things
you